Hello there!
How do vision transformers work?
Ah, this is what I have been asking myself
lately too!
We’re already tired of hearing news about
Vision Transformers beating state-of-the-art
here, and there, everywhere!
– everywhere in computer vision means ImageNet.
But we have also come to see vision transformers
with convolutional biases in them,
like the hierarchical Swin Transformer which
has a limited attention window and we started
to get some mixed feelings about what works
best.
Is it now convolutions or is it multi-head
self-attention?
In the last video, we got entirely confused
about who wins the fight between ConvNets
and Transformers:
We saw with ConvNeXt how a modernized ConvNet
can compete with transformers.
So, it’s time to read and explain this paper
that brings more insight into what makes vision
transformers so special
(multi-head self-attention!).
And why they are maybe not as special as we
think or not for the reasons we originally
had in mind.
wandb.alert() Oh, here is my alert that we
should thank Weights & Biases for supporting
us for this video!
Today, we want to highlight the Weights & Biases
Alert feature.
You can be notified via Slack or email if
your W&B Run has crashed or whether a custom
trigger has been reached,
such as your loss going to NaN or a step in
your ML pipeline has completed.
W&B Alerts apply to all projects where your
launch runs, including both personal and Team
projects.
Get started with W&B Alerts in 2 quick steps:
Turn on alerts in your weights and biases
User Settings.
You can get notified via slack and/or email
for whether your run is finished, whether
it has crashed or any other custom trigger
you like.
For custom triggers, add wandb.alert to your
code, wherever you’d like to be alerted
for a custom trigger.
I’ve been told that Weights & Biases users
love Alerts and that some have saved large
cloud GPU bills by being alerted early to
crashed runs while training large, expensive
models.
So relatable!
Try out Weights & Biases Alerts now at: http://wandb.me/ai-coffee-break
Great, let’s go back to today’s topic
of comparing multi-head self-attention with
convolutions.
We got mixed signals about Vision Transformers
during the last decades in Machine Learning…
eh, whom are we kidding?
ViT was published September 2020 which admittedly
feels like a decade ago, because of the insane
pace of the field.
If you want a recap about Vision Transformers,
do check out our playlist about them.
Here we make a quick recap on Multi-Head Self-Attention
or short MSA and convolutions.
The convolutional layer involves a kernel,
basically a small matrix containing some numbers
that slides over the input and processes every
region in the same manner:
It’s the same kernel values that get multiplied
with the different values of the input.
So, the parameters are shared between image
locations, inducing translation equivariance
since if we move the input across the image
and we apply the same weights everywhere in
the image, the output will remain the same
but translate accordingly.
Sharing parameters, so having the same parameters
independently of the image region, is also
a big plus if one wants to save memory.
But then there is Multi-Head Self-Attention
or MSA in short that laughs at the whole concept
of sharing parameters across the spatial dimension
and instead dynamically computes a weight
for each token.
We remember the sequence spans across the
spatial dimension.
Let’s break this down:
We remember that 16 by 16 image patches are
represented as vectors, or in other words,
image tokens.
To compute a new representation for this image
token here, first, attention scores are computed
between this token and every other token in
the sequence, including oneself.
Then, the representations of these image tokens
are aggregated by a weighted sum in which
the weight of each token is given by the attention
score.
So, in this example here, this token contributes
a lot for computing this new representation,
this other token only very little.
Of course, we do this for all tokens.
So before, we had convolutions that compute
a new representation for each pixel by taking
the sum between all the pixels in a region
weighted by the entries of the kernel.
And now, we have the self-attention layer.
The result of which is a weighted average
of all these image vectors that represent
patches (like with convolutions), but now
the weights of the sum are
first: positive, and second dynamically computed
through this renowned formula where we remember
that the data itself is considered here in
the keys and queries.
In other words, these attention scores are
highly data dependent and not static like
the kernel values of the convolution.
Don’t be confused: We are talking about
inference here or about one iteration during
training.
Of course, kernel values update during training
so they can adapt to the data and the task
at hand.
When we say that Convs are static we mean
that at one iteration or at inference time,
they are fixed and do not depend on the data
sample or spatial region in the data, while
attention weights are computed for each data
vector individually.
Another difference between MSAs and Convs
is that for MSAs, the weighted aggregation
is done over the entire input,
so unlike convolutions in CNNs that are usually
small windows like 3x3 and encompass a small
spatial range in the image,
self-attention encompasses a much longer range:
the whole image.
And why did we say that MSA laughs at the
concept of saving memory?
Well, while self-attention computes one score
between each two image tokens, multi-head
self-attention says:
Eh, come on!
Why decide for only one set of scores when
I can have 2.
Or 6, or 12!
In this way, the network does not have to
rely on one combination of attention scores,
but on many of them that have the chance to
specialize.
This idea follows the motto that ensembling
is in general beneficial.
In a similar manner, convolutional networks
do not work with only one kernel per layer,
but with more of them where the weights can
be adapted during training to specialize for
specific features.
Great, this was the short recap on MSAs versus
Convs, and we basically only explained the
background of this little paragraph in the
paper.
So, assuming we already know the key components
of Vision Transformers, during the last one
and a half year in which we had time to study
them, we still got quite the mixed signals
about what is now exactly the difference between
Convs and MSAs.
And this is what I love about this paper:
it puts all of this together to get a more
coherent picture about what exactly makes
vision transformers great.
The introduction of the paper reminds us of
what we have been saying previously in our
videos too.
We think that the success of transformers
in general and MSA in particular, is due to
two main reasons:
First, the weak inductive bias of MSA.
While convolutions have this parameter-sharing
property throughout the spatial dimension,
MSA doesn’t.
So, each image region can be handled by its
own specific attention weights.
Even more, these attention weights are data-specific,
as we discussed earlier.
So there are more degrees of freedom when
modelling with MSA than with convolutions
and the network has the chance to discover
translation equivariance on its own and even
cooler properties, if they are useful for
minimizing the loss!
And because there is less guidance from the
start for the network, Vision Transformers
are notorious to overfit on small datasets.
It shall remain to be seen in this video whether
this is true.
But we know that techniques involving heavy
data augmentation are needed for small data
regimes as we have seen with DeiT making ViT
work on smaller datasets.
The second reason is the extremely large context
window of vanilla MSA that computes attention
scores for each token based on every single
other token.
Attending to a wider context should lead to
better performance, right?
Right?
Let’s follow this paper’s related work
to see why this is not really the case.
Modelling long-range dependencies does not
necessarily result in higher performance.
There are examples in the literature showing
how a
limited context window of MSA is beneficial
on small and large datasets alike, like we
have seen with the Swin Transformer in one
of our previous videos.
And then, there’s these facts we should
make sense of: Adding MSA to CNNs… helps,
especially when MSA is added closer to the
last layer.
And then, we cite “ViTs are robust against
data corruption and image occlusions” and
especially against adversarial attacks where
the attack consists of introducing high-frequency
noise.
So, what is it with MSA and the insensitivity
to high frequencies, now?
Ok, hold your questions because this paper
is going to address them by
hypothesising that MSA is “a trainable spatial
smoothing of feature maps”.
And this makes sense when looking at the formula
of self-attention: We take the image vectors,
or features across the spatial dimension,
and average them with importance-weights that
are all positive.
So, the authors go ahead and ask three questions:
“What properties of MSAs do we need to better
optimize NNs?”,
“Do MSAs act like Convs?
If not, how are they different?”
and third, “How can we harmonize MSAs with
Convs?”.
Following this last question, they propose
an architecture combining MSA and Convolutions
based on the lessons learned from answering
the first two questions.
Before going further into this, Ms. Coffee
Bean wants me to make a small comment on how
the authors arrived at their conclusions.
The authors answered these questions by conducting
their experiments on…
CIFAR only.
I mean, it is great that they compare different
models like the ResNet-50 (which is a ConvNet)
and transformers like ViT, PiT, and Swin.
It’s problematic again that they use the
tiny versions of these models.
But we have two questions: What about datasets
other than CIFAR?
And how do the lessons of this paper generalize
for tasks other than image classification,
so for something like object detection or
image segmentation?
Keep this in mind throughout this video.
Let’s follow the paper and answer the first
question: “What properties of MSAs do we
need to improve optimization?”.
Well, the first lesson here is unsurprising:
It seems like MSA is acting like a more generalized
spatial smoothing.
Generalized, because it is trainable and data-dependent.
And this is a good inductive bias for image
data.
Only think about the data-specificity: it’s
a nice thing to have, something we do not
find in a data-independent aggregation layer
like we have in the MLP-Mixer.
Nothing against the MLP-Mixer, it’s really
useful if we dislike the compute and memory
footprint of MSA and are ready for a compromise
in accuracy.
The surprising bit is that due to the weaker
inductive bias of MSA, the training of MSA-based
neural networks is more difficult:
They do not even overfit small training datasets!
We see here how the two curves for training
and test of ViT on CIFAR-100 are very close
to each other and are not exhibiting the gap
specific to overfitting, not even in the small
data regimes.
Of course, this is also helped by the strong
DeiT like data augmentation the authors apply
to ViT.
Also interesting, but not surprising after
we have learned about Swin Transformers and
ConvNeXts, is that not the huge context window
of MSA is the recipe to success, but a reduction
of the degrees of freedom by limiting MSA
to very small windows.
We see in this picture how the lowest test
error is achieved with a 3x3 window size for
MSA.
But Ms. Coffee Bean must comment again on
this because the authors conduct experiments
on CIFAR-100 where we would assume that long
dependencies are not key for good performance.
We expect this lesson to vary on more complex
datasets and on tasks other than image recognition.
Image recognition is too holistic for this,
I guess.
Describing the whole image with one label
is not very challenging and we would like
to see results on other tasks like action
recognition where it is important to model
how two different corners of the image interact
with one another.
But a cool thing to find out is that MSA comes
with both advantages and disadvantages.
On the bright side, MSAs flatten the loss
landscapes.
A flat landscape means better performance
and generalization because you know, landing
here or landing there on the loss landscape
does not change much.
In a less flat landscape, it means a lot if
I land here or over there.
But how do the authors know that the landscape
is flatter for MSA?
Well, they look at the eigenvalues of the
Hessian matrix.
Short reminder, the Hessian matrix of the
loss function is a square matrix containing
the second partial derivatives of the loss
function.
In English, please:
We take two directions in our high-dimensional
space that the loss function lives in and
ask how does the change in one direction change
with respect to the other direction?
And the eigenvectors of this Hessian matrix
are the principal directions of curvature.
The eigenvalues speak about the magnitude
of that curvature.
A big Hessian eigenvalue speaks for high curvature,
so for a very curvy and supposedly bumpy loss
landscape.
And guess what, MSA suppresses large Hessian
eigenvalues!
So this makes the loss landscape flatter for
ViT, while the loss landscape of the ResNet
has high Hessian eigenvalues, thus a higher
curvature.
This is a win for MSA!
On the not so bright side for MSA, the authors
read another thing from the Hessian of the
loss function:
Especially in the regimes of little data,
a lot of Hessian eigenvalues turn out to be
negative, so the loss landscape is non-convex
for MSA.
And if you hear “non-convex”, prepare
for local minima that your optimizer might
not escape from!
But the good news is that more data also makes
for less negative Hessian eigenvalues, so
more convex losses.
Given that in small data regimes the loss
landscape is non-convex, it is again interesting
to see that ViT does not overfit when training
on small datasets [whisper] local minima!
So now, what is the difference between MSA
and Convolutions?
First, something we have discussed already:
convolutions are data-agnostic and MSAs are
data-specific.
Secondly, convolutions are channel-specific
where kernels are learned for each channel.
And MSA does not care on which channel they
are applied.
In fact, the patches that first consist of
3 channels, for red, green and blue are all
smashed together into one vector.
So if, we cite, “Convs are data-agnostic
and channel-specific.
In contrast, MSAs are data-specific and channel
agnostic.”, then the conclusion of this
paper is that they should be complementary.
Nice.
More interesting for Ms. Coffee Bean is that
“MSAs are low-pass filters, but Convs are
high-pass filters”.
What does this mean now?
A low pass filter lets the low frequencies
pass,
so things like shape and wide patterns in
the image get through, while sharp details
do not.
Think about the low frequencies as the information
that remains after blurring the image.
Convolutions on the other hand, are high-pass
filters meaning that they let high frequencies
pass, like very fine edges in texture.
Therefore, it is no wonder that, we cite “The
results thus suggests that MSAs are shape-biased,
whereas Convs are texture-biased.“ Which
also confirms findings of previous work.
The authors see this by doing a Fourier decomposition
of ViT and ResNet features respectively and
comparing the resulting frequencies.
Also, we are not surprised that CNNs which
are high-pass filters, not filtering out high
frequencies, are vulnerable to high-frequency
noise and adversarial attacks that introduce
high frequencies into the image – so high
that the human eye cannot even see.
And the last difference we will discuss here
between MSAs and Convs is that MSAs average
feature maps and reduce the variance of the
feature maps—an ensembling-like effect.
The authors support this by showing how MSAs
rather reduce the variance and Convs and MLPs
increase the variance, in their experiments
.
So it is no wonder that based on this, the
authors move on to the third question of the
paper of “How can we harmonize MSAs with
Convs?”
and propose AlterNet which in a nutshell is
a ResNet with MSA blocks after each stage,
especially at late stages to reduce feature
map variance.
We will let you decide what you think about
this architecture after you find out about
all its details.
Honestly, due to the limited datasets, tasks,
and baselines explored in this paper, we are
not very impressed by AlterNet.
But we have seen with ConvNeXt that an enhanced
ResNet can achieve good performance, so we
do believe the authors’ message here that
marrying Convs with MSA seems like a good
idea.
If you want to know all the details that we
missed or got wrong, read the paper.
We have mixed feelings about its style: On
the one hand, it has a good choice of words
and flow of ideas, but it is also extremely
dense and sometimes the required details are
in unexpected places.
Thanks for watching and sorry you had to wait
for so long for this video to come.
PhD life is… demanding and Ms. Coffee Bean
isn’t animating herself.
Okay, bye.